Destiny is in court accused of sharing intimate videos without
permission. He has been slandering the victim, Pixie, and her
attorneys in front of his audience of rabid fans. Pixie's attorneys
requested to protect their witnesses from the public to ensure
they wouldn't have their names in public court documents for
Destiny to review on stream. For the last two weeks, Destiny
has claimed Pixie's attorneys were violating procedure, telling
his audience he hoped the judge would sanction Pixie's attorneys
for breaking the rules. I hope there are sanctions for opposing
council after this. I but I'm hoping as part of a summary judgement
that there are I hope that opposing council is punished for the
behavior because they've violated like several rules at this
point. Today when Pixie was granted all of her requests to seal
witnesses, he is pretending it was totally expected and proper.
Despite attacking the victims and their witnesses the last two
weeks leave pages paperless order granting for the motion for
file
procedal unredacted declarations for IBM.
Okay, this is fine. Sure. Um, they keep they keep trying to cite
these like local rules for how they want to file things under
seal like local rule 5.4 B1. If you read these like the local
rules or if you know anything about civil procedure, you you
can't file stuff under seal and keep it from the defense. You
just can't do that. I don't know why they keep trying to make
this argument that they can. Like Destiny knows the Pixie attorneys
were going to provide him with the information of the witnesses.
He said it himself. certain statements by witnesses which purpose
is to keep their names out of the public. You and your client
will know their identities because you have to. Duh. He's reading
the words of Pixie's attorneys. You and your client will know
their identities because you have to. Duh. Wait, what do we get
over on? How close to destiny to winning? We have to make it
through the discovery phase. Oh, whoever posted that is buying
the coping narrative. What is the cope on how we There's no excuse
not to share the unredacted docs with you. No, no, you have to
do that. Of course. Oh, the court finds good cause plaintiff
to file under seal the unredacted declarations. Is this supposed
to be a loss? Like everything about this is just a joke. I just
I can't, dude. I I'm praying. I'm praying. I'm praying.
Um, is this supposed to be a loss defense? You just can't do
that. I don't know why they keep trying to make this argument
that they can. There's nothing wrong with them filing stuff under
seal, especially for a case like this. I think it's appropriate
this. I think it's appropriate. Destiny has doxed Pixie and many
of the witnesses. Yes, I think it's appropriate. The issue is
them filing things under seal and then keeping them from us.
You can't keep that from us. That's insane. You and your client
will know their identities because you have to. Duh. However,
yeah, that's fine. It seems because they have to file unredacted
declarations so that we would have all that information. Yeah,
this I think it's appropriate. Wait, what do we get over on?
Is this supposed to be a loss? They tried to sell it in a way
that you expected the underseal filing motion to not be granted.
I think generally
um I don't know if it's that hard to file things under seal and
I'm not sure if we really fought that hard against filing it
under seal. The big deal was them filing stuff but like keeping
it from us like not telling us who it was. So if they file under
seal an unredacted declaration then that means that we have all
the information. Like I'm fine with that. That's fine. You just
can't do that. I don't know why they keep trying to make this
argument that they can. You and your client will know their identities
because you have to. Duh. There's no way she tweeted that. Wait,
what? Court update. Good news. Despite opposition from Destiny's
Council, the court has granted us the ability to keep witnesses
identity under seal. If you have any information regarding a
case, we can file to keep your name out of public and protected
by the court. I mean, like that doesn't really make any sense,
but okay. There's nothing wrong with them filing stuff under
seal, especially for a case like this. I think it's appropriate.
It doesn't really make any sense, but okay. Because their council's
claim was that I was the one that was personally harassing and
intimidating people. And if you file under seal, I still get
the name. So theoretically, I would still be able to harass people.
But hey, listen, be based. I would still be able to harass people.
But I I could I trust to do it. I do not want someone or I do
want someone to kill the school though or lab or Mr. or Queen.
All those people can go die. Just has mentioned himself. He plans
to provide a statement only if he gets protection due to the
public death threats against him by destiny. Destiny is by definition
intimidating
witnesses. I could I trust to do it. I do not want someone or
I do want someone to kill though or lab or Mr. Orman. All those
people can go die. None of this if you really think you have
a strong argument here which fine say you do say okay well I
think that the I think defense is is trying to murder all of
the witness or whatever. File that with the court. They did and
he lost. Now, Destiny's victims can come forward.
Under seal is public. Destiny still knows who it is. Well, Under
Seal is private or rather just the court holds on to it and the
public can't see, but I would I would say obviously not that
it mattered. I don't do witness intimidation that I'm just kidding.
I can't make a joke about it because it'll show up in their next
I could I show up there to do it. I do not want someone or I
do want someone to kill the school though or lab or Mr. Orman.
All those people can go die. Not that it mattered. I don't do
witness intimidation that I'm just kidding. And I can't make
a joke about it cuz it'll show up in their next writing of lying
and perjury. He refers to the undersigned council as disgusting.
Oh, that's them. Nice. I am. Yes. Include this in your next I
look forward to being in your next court filing. That's right.
I think you are. Um and repeatedly accuses the undersigned council
of grabbing random people to purchase themselves. I do. I'll
show me your next filing. I'm here. Thumbs up. Link me. Put a
screenshot. In closing, this is a small point about Pixie's attorneys
asking for the ability to go over the 10-page limit for the recent
motion. Destiny admits it was expected. Paperless order granting
44 motion for leave to file excess pages. Whoever finds good
cause to grant the requested expansion of pagement. This is expected.
You're probably always I think it would take like an exceptional
circumstance for them to say no extra pages. Although the extra
pages they filed were stupid yet had his attorney fight pixie
tooth and nail to make everything as difficult as possible for
the victims.
Motion to file under seal certain documents and his proposed
order. Motion for leave to exceed page limit on reply memorandum
um because they wanted to file an extra long uh insane reply
instead of just a normal 10 pages. The documents be filed under
seal are repetitive, wordy, improperly formatted and contained
a myriad of extraneous and irrelevant information. The court
should constrain plaintiff to the 10-page limit that they didn't
need to file. And if we would have had a meeting and confer before,
we probably wouldn't have okayed. I would imagine we would have
fought on this motion to exceed page limit because it's they
didn't need 20 pages to say a bunch of like Okay. Um Okay. The
local rules